so we're working backwards now now we're
back to thanksgiving thursday
and donald trump finally took questions
from reporters
sort of technically although he didn't
actually answer
a single question in a real way he did
attack a reporter and we're going to
look at that in a moment
trump didn't even hesitate to come out
and tell the lies
that his flunkies and tools and cronies
and lawyers have been telling for weeks
about this election
now i know that some of these clips have
blue flashes and some audio glitches
they are not our glitches the master
video we got of the event
for some reason contains some of these
glitches take a listen to this first
clip
and i'm serious if the media were honest
and a big tech were honest which it's
totally not
it's it's a terrible thing that whole
section 230 is a disgrace that they even
have it
but big tech is totally dishonest if the
media were honest and big tank was fair
this wouldn't even be a contest and i
would have won by
a tremendous amount a tremendous amount
and i did win by a tremendous amount but
it hasn't been reported yet
but people understand what's happened
they know what happened
now of course donald trump did not win
by any amount never mind a tremendous
one
but he continues to say it and then he
starts getting asked
really specific questions like will you
go to joe biden's inauguration and check
out how he handles it of course it is
tradition
you know that it's tradition for
previous presidents to go to the next
president's inauguration so will you
attend
i don't want to say that yet but i mean
i know the answer i i'll be honest i
know the answer but i just don't want to
say it yet
look a thing like this possibly has
never happened before but maybe
people just didn't catch it but we've
caught it but why are your
journeys we've got hundreds of thousands
of those people
if i made it listen excuse me if i may
when they don't
allow a poll watcher which is a sacred
person in our country people don't know
what a poll watcher is
a poll watcher is it's considered sacred
in our country when they throw them out
of rooms but that's not true they didn't
do that
and when they put them in pens your
attorneys admitted no they didn't my
attorney did not admit anything
this is uh this is really stuff for
history books
will you go to the inauguration well
listen i won
we caught them the pole watchers were in
pens
and they've used the term corraled
before you know giving this idea that
poll watchers were corralled
along with wild hogs and steer eating
cereal and grain from a trough
trump then casually saying they gave
biden lots of votes that weren't really
biden votes
still not a shred i mean not an iota of
evidence for that claim they gave biden
a lot of votes that he
would never have gotten this is not a
candidate that could get a 80
80 million dollars this is just not a
candidate this is not a candidate that
beat
barack hussein obama with the black
voter
okay this is not a candidate that beat
obama with the black voter
this is not a candidate that beat
hillary clinton to a pulp
it just doesn't work that way remember
that all of those claims
are spurious and without evidence and
every court has found that to be the
case so far
trump was then asked despite your claims
that it was rigged and stolen by joe
biden
if the electoral college votes for joe
biden
will you step down and concede and this
caused trump to blow a gasket
and attack the reporter this is just to
be clear if the electoral college votes
for joe biden will
well if they do they made a mistake
because this election
was a fraud just so you understand this
election was a fraud
i mean they have biden beating obama on
obama's vote
in areas that mattered in terms of the
election in swing states
and yet he's losing to obama all over
the place
but he's beating obama in swing states
which are the states that mattered for
purposes of the election
so no i can't say that at all i think
it's a
it's a possibility they're trying to
look between you people
don't answer don't talk to me that way
you're just uh you're just a lightweight
don't talk to me that way
don't talk to i'm the president of the
united states don't ever talk to the
president that way
this is actually very interesting
because people who are respected
and are respectable they never in a
million years have to tell anybody
respect me saying respect me is
something you hear from people
who are difficult to respect who aren't
commanding respect through their actions
and trump says respect me now another
sign of just this sort of
shrunken down uh intellectual
smurf that that is donald trump uh trump
then of course saying that listen
he doesn't believe the georgia elections
are going to be fairly done
and if this leads to republicans simply
not showing up in in the georgia senate
races that would be great take a listen
mr president if you don't think that the
presidential
election was legitimate and if you think
that it was stolen
what confidence do you expect voters in
georgia to have when they go to the
polls to vote for
say lefleur or purdue well i told them
today i think you're dealing with a very
fraudulent system i think
i'm very worried about that they are
tremendous people
kelly leffler david perdue tremendous
people they should be in the united
states senate they're desperately needed
but i told them today i said listen you
have a fraudulent system
you have a system with the flick of a
switch or the putting in of a new chip
can change the course of history and
you have to be very careful and again
the funny thing about this
is there is actually a republican
movement
to boycott the runoff elections in
georgia
oak great have at it that would help
democrats take the senate i encourage
republicans
if they really do believe this system is
fraudulent then just don't participate
leave the voting
uh to those that will be voting for
rafael warnock and john ossoff i would i
would be glad to see that
trump also believes that pennsylvania
state senators are going to overturn the
election
and he falsely claims that he actually
won georgia very easily
in philadelphia you take a look we've
had excellent meetings with
uh senators from
pennsylvania republican senators and
others
uh and they're seeing things they knew
it was dishonest but they didn't know it
was this dishonest no and you'll see it
all
you'll see it also we'll see speaking of
george i'll be going there
i spoke with the two great senators
they're great senators kelly and david
i'll probably be going on saturday we're
looking for a site we're going to have a
tremendous turnout and we seem to always
have a good turnout
the people are very disappointed that we
were robbed
listen uh republicans in pennsylvania
are telling trump he won so he must have
won
and trump mentioning a rally in georgia
there he said saturday people thought it
meant this past saturday
i guess it's going to be this coming
saturday december
uh fifth i guess that is we will
certainly cover it live
if it happens and then just a final
moment of insanity trump claiming that
all of the election results in georgia
michigan wisconsin and pennsylvania
were fraud in a completely deranged
outburst
signatures the reason they don't want to
show her signatures is very simple
because we will find thousands and
thousands a very close race it's hair
thin
but we'll find thousands and thousands
of discrepancies
fraud why they aren't wanting to show
those signatures is amazing
they're doing recounts and even in the
recount they found thousands of votes
that were off
but now we want to look at the
signatures and you will find tens of
thousands of false ballots
frauds forged ballots you'll see it
all over you're going to see a lot of it
and you go to pennsylvania you saw the
meeting we had yesterday with
pennsylvania
you saw people come up and they went to
vote and they said no
you can't vote somebody else already
sent in a ballot
and a woman but this is happening tens
of thousands of times
i think it was 600 and some odd thousand
six hundred and eighty seven thousand
uh fraudulent votes cast in pennsylvania
and i will tell you the if you look at
the state house now the republican state
house they're starting to see what's
going on there
but they've really known it for a long
time then you go to michigan
and you look at what happened in wayne
county in detroit i went through a list
so trump just goes on and on claiming
that he really won everything
there was a woman and there was a guy
and some irregularities
biden didn't really win is the takeaway
and this is the deranged stuff that
you know you would hope would never
happen in the united states like as
toxic as american politics is
you wouldn't expect that it would get
this bad
except this time we did expect it and we
were right to
all of those republican hot takes saying
you guys are going overboard
trump's never going to do any of this
he's doing all of it he's never conceded
he's claiming he's won six or more
states that he lost
he won't commit to going to the
inauguration he won't stop filing
lawsuit after lawsuit to try to steal it
our most catastrophic predictions
all came true incredibly now the
question is what will he do
in the remaining time up until january
20th
what a time to be alive my friends
one of our sponsors is hydrant which is
a delicious fruit drink powder that you
mix
into water for rehydration and they're
giving you
25 off your first order it's made with
four key electrolytes that the body
needs
powerfully supporting your hydration
hydrant tastes great
it's made with real fruit juice it's
been a great part of my daily routine
for a while now
keeping myself hydrated puts me in a
better mood
the body needs hydration for basic
energy and focus and hydrant is the
perfect way to rehydrate
especially because it's cost effective
and lower in sugar compared to all of
those popular
sports drinks that are out there you
really have to try it for yourself to
see what i mean
it tastes great they also have a variety
called hydrant immunity packed with
vitamins a
b c and d which is also very much worth
trying
hydrant has a full refund guarantee if
you're not satisfied and you'll get 25
off your first order when you go to
drink hydrant.com
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video